let's talk about the only carbohydrate
that
will not influence
insulin now as you may know insulin is
the hormone that makes you fat it's the
hormone that prevents you from burning
fat
and it's a fat storing hormone so in the
presence of even a little bit of insulin
it's going to be very difficult to lose
weight and get into ketosis so the only
carb that has absolutely no influence
over insulin
is fiber okay now the problem with fiber
is it normally comes with
other carbs that do influence insulin as
in the bread pasta cereal crackers
biscuits waffles
things like that and so many times
people are recommending those foods
because it has fiber but what about the
other carbs that are not fiber we want
to stay away from them
now just as a side note
pure fat
will also not increase
insulin but what does increase insulin
is the sugar the starches
and excessive amounts of protein
so is it just a matter of getting some
fiber maybe some metamucil on a spoon
and then pour some pure fat on it right
no the type of fiber that you need is in
the non-starchy
leafy greens it's in the vegetables and
this is why you don't have to count
non-starchy vegetables when you're doing
the ketogenic diet as a part of your
grams of carbohydrate
normally you want to keep your carbs
below 30 maybe 40 grams maybe even 20
grams but i don't recommend even
counting the non-starchy vegetables like
the salads and things in fact
unless you have some intestinal damage
or inflammatory condition that
causes bloating when you eat a lot of
vegetables i recommend you do add a good
amount of vegetables as part of a
healthy keto plan and i'm talking at
least seven cups it's not that much
it's like a nice sized salad but what do
these vegetables give you besides fiber
well it gives you minerals potassium
magnesium
to prevent
cramps when you start the ketogenic diet
to prevent
keto fatigue when you start the
ketogenic plant also these vegetables
have trace minerals they're loaded with
vitamins like vitamin c folate
other b vitamins they have a tremendous
amount of
phytonutrients which go beyond just the
regular vitamins and minerals
phytonutrients are anti-cancer
anti-inflammatory and they will help
prevent a lot of different issues but as
far as the fiber in the vegetable that
is the food for your microbiome for your
friendly bacteria that's what they eat
and then they turn that fiber into
a type of fat it's called a small chain
fatty acid as in beta
hydroxybutyrate which is a ketone so
butyrate made from your microbes is in
the family of ketones so microbes eat
the fiber
and they make compounds
that help lessen insulin resistance
which is directly going to help you lose
weight because they also help lower
blood glucose they can actually increase
insulin sensitivity which will then make
it easier to lose weight which means
your body won't have to make as much
insulin and that's going to help your
weight loss the fiber also increases the
diversity of microbes which will have
another positive effect on weight loss
all right thanks for watching
hey before you go
if you're benefiting from any of my
content
i would love to hear about your success
story
please share it in the link down below